but one of the most amazing things about
women that think you get no credit for
ladies the most unbelievable impressive
thing is your ability to hide everything
everything is a goddamn secret you're
all in the CIA you have the real you
then be you you let us see we'll go with
menstration pretty big deal let's start
there you hide it pretty goddamn well
men are clueless we have to
guess is that time of the month what do
you think time of the month is she
acting weird you what anything think
time of the month you realize men got
there appear there be blood everywhere
on the walls the sidewalk everywhere
everywhere just guys walking to work a
[__] uterine lining Jesus Christ holy
hell God damn it give me one of those
masculine napkins thank you yeah oh yeah
you too huh Jeff guess we're synced up
yeah there we go all right there we go
says don't flush it but [__]
it